Video games have come a long way over the
years.
We've gone from the days of Atari and "Pong"
to virtual reality headsets, PS5s, and massively
multiplayer online games where you can fight
horror movies villains, or wage war in a fantasy
land.
You can mine virtual minerals and avoid creepers
in "Minecraft," compete against people all
over the world in "Fortnite" and do whatever
it is people do in "Roblox."
Games used to be a pixelated hero battling
blobby monsters with no discernible facial
features, and now they have graphics so detailed
you can see the freckles on a protagonist's
face and each individual blade of grass.
But there's one thing that hasn't changed,
no matter how much progress games may make:
whenever a shiny new console comes out, everyone
wants to get their hands on it.
It was Christmas season in 1986, "Walk Like
an Egyptian" by the Bangles was at the top
of the charts, Eddie Murphy's "The Golden
Child" was the number one movie in America,
and hundreds of thousands of kids were writing
to Santa - and begging their parents - for
one thing: the Nintendo Entertainment System.
The NES was an 8-bit home video game console,
and the only place to journey through the
land of Hyrule in "The Legend of Zelda" or
help Samus hunt Space Pirates in "Metroid."
But with such an extreme demand for the system,
stores were selling out all over the country.
Anyone who didn't beat the crowds was doomed
to disappoint their kids with socks, with
less flashy toys like dolls or tiny plastic
trucks, or with boring, non-electric, violence-free
board games.
Well, board games are only violence-free if
you're not playing "Monopoly."
But back to 1986.
Beverly Harrington was a single mom, doing
her best to provide for her son, Jason, and
give him the Christmas he deserved.
She had been picking up extra shifts at the
local diner, making sure to save up all of
the extra money for a real Christmas tree
from the farm just out of town, for a beautiful
honey-baked ham, and, of course, for presents.
She knew that, though he was a shy kid and
would never demand it, Jason desperately wanted
to find an NES under the tree on Christmas
morning.
She got so absorbed in her work, so exhausted
from the extra shifts and trying to make everything
perfect, that she forgot to do her actual
shopping until the very last minute.
She woke up the morning of December 24 with
a start, her heart jumping into her throat.
She hadn't picked up Jason's present yet!
She threw on her coat and rushed out into
the snowy streets, making her way to the store
and saying a silent prayer that they would
still have one more NES in stock.
Lucky for her, they did!
Less lucky, two parents were already wrestling
for it, fighting each other with the raw animalistic
rage of two wolves competing for the same
piece of meat.
If she tried to grab it and join in, she could
get hurt, or the console could break apart.
She asked an employee if they had any in the
back, but she already knew the answer from
the exhausted look in his eyes.
There were no more in the back.
There were no more in town, or the next town
over, or the next town over from that.
Not only would she have to get Jason's present
at the very last minute, but she would also
have to get him something he didn't even want.
He would smile and thank her, but she knew
how sad it would make him to go back to school
and hear his friends bragging about their
Christmases.
She shoved her hands into the pockets of her
coat, and began her slow, sad march back through
the snow, trying to come up with what to do
next.
Then, something caught her eye, a brightly-colored
sign reading "Wondertaining Toys."
Beneath it, was a storefront she had never
seen before, and right there in the window,
a video game console.
It wasn't the NES, not exactly, but it looked
so much like it…
She couldn't help herself, she had to go inside
and get a better look.
The store was filled with toys, games, and
puzzles.
They were all inviting, with vivid packaging
and labels depicting children having fun,
but she had never seen any of them before.
Perhaps it was a new brand, and she was one
of the first people to happen upon the store?
It seemed odd for a toy store to open this
close to Christmas, rather than taking advantage
of the shopping season and opening earlier
in the year...But she couldn't dwell on that,
not when she was this close to a solution.
Toward the back of the store, she spotted
the video game console from the window.
The label read, "Pretendo."
So the resemblance to the NES was no coincidence,
this console was intended as a knockoff of
some kind.
She asked the sales clerk, a man with a strangely
wide, unmoving smile, if the console was capable
of running Nintendo games.
"You bet your bottom dollar!"
He replied.
"We don't carry those here, though.
But can I interest you in some of our Wondertainment
originals?
We have all kinds of games here, and they're
just as good or your money back!
There's a whole world inside each and every
one."
It wasn't what she'd set out to buy, but this
was clearly the best thing Beverly was going
to find this close to the holiday.
She paid the man for the Pretendo console
and a selection of the store's most popular
video games.
He even gift-wrapped it for her in a colorful
box, with a shiny red bow on top.
The next morning, Jason and Beverly sat in
the living room, sipping cocoa and opening
presents together.
She started small, with the classic pair of
new wool socks, and worked her way up to the
big box in the corner.
As Jason tore the paper off, his eyes lit
up with glee.
"Thank you, mom!
Thank you!"
He gave her a huge hug, then looked at her
with nearly manic excitement.
"Can I play it now?
Can I?"
She laughed and promised that after he helped
her clean up the wrapping paper, he could
play his new games.
She was just so glad he was happy with it.
He didn't care that it wasn't the name-brand
console, he knew that this gift was special.
So she was perfectly glad to let him enjoy
it, and she could get started on that ham
for later.
Jason plugged in his brand new Pretendo, and
looked through the games his mom had picked
out for him.
There was "Farmtastic!
Farming simulator", "Historical House Hunter",
"Magic Wizard Quest," "Super Fighters," and
one simply called, "Spooky."
It was emblazoned with the image of a cartoon
ghost in front of an abandoned cabin, and
it piqued Jason's interest.
He had always loved scary stories and legends
about ghosts and things that go bump in the
night.
He decided this would be his first game.
He placed the cartridge in the console and
hit the power button to turn it on.
As he clutched the controller in his hands,
he began to notice something strange.
His room, once decorated in posters of his
favorite movies, turned dark.
The light green walls became rotting wood.
And, for lack of a better way to describe
it, the entire world's resolution began to
shift.
If the world around him had graphics, they
were getting worse.
He could no longer see the screen depicting
the game's main menu, and in fact, the console
itself had vanished.
Somehow, he was standing in the haunted cabin
from the cover of the game.
He looked down at his hands and found the
controller still there.
So, not everything had changed...
Before he could think any more about this
strange new place he found himself in, he
heard the sound of ominous music, seemingly
coming from nowhere.
After a moment, he realized why the sound
of its melody filled him with dread...it was
the kind of music that always played in a
game when an enemy was getting close.
He had to move.
He took a step forward, and he moved through
the space as if it was a real house.
For the time being, it was.
Somehow, he was inside the game.
Which meant...the ghost was coming for him
soon.
He pressed a button on the controller to activate
a flashlight, and followed its beam through
the darkened cabin.
As he walked, looking for clues or any object
he could interact with, he could hear the
music getting louder.
Whatever was coming, it was getting closer.
The flashlight's beam illuminated a scrap
of paper on a small table.
He moved to take a closer look, and could
just barely make out what it said.
"They hide in the darkness.
Find the exit.
Don't stop moving.
"
He heard a sound behind him, and the music
reached a deafening volume.
He whirled around, and saw nothing but the
hall in front of him, bending around a corner.
He knew, from the heavy feeling in the pit
of his stomach and the music that threatened
to rupture his eardrums, that there was something
horrible waiting for him around that corner.
He froze for a moment, then remembered the
letter's words of warning, "don't stop moving."
He took a step toward the corner, then another,
and another.
He shone the light of the flashlight around
the corner, but there was nothing there.
No ghost, no monster.
Nothing.
And then he felt it.
A chill on the back of his neck.
He whirled around, and there it was.
The ghost of the cabin.
It was so much bigger than it had looked before,
wispy white form stretching up to the ceiling,
from wall to wall, its wide dark eyes and
gaping maw of a mouth inches from his own
face.
He screamed and instinctively swung the flashlight
at the spirit, cutting through it with a beam
of light.
The ghost let out a shriek and shrank away
from the glow.
That was it!
He just needed to keep the light on it, and
the ghost couldn't hurt him.
Jason was so thrilled by this little victory
that he didn't notice the boss music starting
to play again, growing louder and louder.
He didn't see the movement out of the corner
of his eye, the silvery pale figure of a woman
stepping out of a portrait on the wall.
All he felt was a sudden, overwhelming cold,
like ice in his veins, and then everything
went black.
He opened his eyes back in his bedroom, looking
at a dark screen with the words GAME OVER
written in dripping red font.
He couldn't tell for a moment if that had
been real or a dream, but either way, he only
wanted to do one thing: tell his mom.
Beverly listened to her son's story, and couldn't
help but write it off as the overactive imagination
of a child.
But still, she humored him and agreed to try
the console for herself and see what happened.
Choosing at random, she selected "Farmtastic!"
and pressed "play."
All of a sudden, she felt the heat of the
sun on her face, heard the mooing of cows,
and smelled fresh-cut hay.
She was steering a tractor through a wide-open
field, where a moment ago she had been standing
in her house in the dead of winter.
Jason shut off the game, pulling her back
into reality, and as Beverly gaped in shock,
Jason said "Best!
Present!
EVER!"
Unfortunately for Jason, word was already
spreading about the Pretendo, all the way
to the SCP Foundation.
The console, and all other consoles that the
Foundation could track down, were seized and
designated SCP-591.
SCP-591 is a line of video game consoles originally
developed as a counterfeit of the Nintendo
Entertainment System, before being bought
and distributed by Doctor Wondertainment,
a toy company responsible for a wide variety
of anomalous objects contained by the Foundation
over the years.
The console is capable of playing NES titles
as well as games from Doctor Wondertainment's
original lineup of 8-bit games, many of which
the Foundation has in its possession as well.
Some of the titles in the SCP Foundation library
include, but are not limited to, arcade shooter
"Whap 'Em!", platformer "Dusky's Adventures
in Staedland," survival horror game "You Can
Do That on Television," puzzle game "WWI Ace
Trench Digger," music/racing game "Led Zeppelin
Air Racers," fightings games "Super Kick Karate"
and "Super Kick Karate 2010," and the educational
game "Reading Rainbow Sit and Listen."
Whenever one of the official Doctor Wondertainment
cartridges is inserted into the console and
activated, it results in a localized CK-class
reality restructuring scenario, which rearranges
reality in the immediate area to resemble
the game's setting.
The player inside of the game's affected radius
will take on the role of the game's protagonist,
and navigate the events of the game until
they either win or the console is deactivated.
Don't worry, this isn't one of those "if you
die in the game you die in real life" scenarios.
If the player happens to be a less than adept
gamer, they will simply respawn or start at
the beginning of the game like any video game
character would.
That doesn't, however, mean that SCP-591 isn't
dangerous.
Like any piece of vintage technology, the
components of the Pretendo system have degraded
over time, their functionality steadily decreasing.
For an ordinary game console, this would be
a simple inconvenience, something that would
impact the quality of the graphics or the
responsiveness of the controls.
It would be annoying, and maybe eventually
unplayable, but otherwise harmless.
For the Pretendo, however, this degradation
has had catastrophic effects.
When a game cartridge is inserted into SCP-591,
there is now a chance of the CK-class reality
restructuring scenario going wrong, and resulting
in a ZK-class reality failure scenario instead.
Essentially, instead of just transporting
the player into the world of the game, reality
will crumble in the designated area and the
laws of time, space, and physics will be bent
or even broken.
While the CK-class scenarios dissipate as
soon as the console is deactivated, the ZK-class
scenarios refuse to play by the rules.
They remain in place wherever they first manifested,
seemingly permanently.
The ZK-class scenarios were first observed
during play-testing by the research staff
assigned to SCP-591.
After learning about the nature of the Pretendo
game system, Dr. Furakawa has volunteered
as a test subject, specifically requesting
that he be given the chance to play the Dr.
Wondertainment title "The Legend of Sword
Master," because, quote, "It just looks really
cool."
This particular game came with not just the
cartridge, but a special sword-shaped controller,
to be used during the sword fight sequences.
Dr. Furakawa stepped into the containment
cell where one instance of SCP-591 had been
placed, with his chosen game cartridge and
controller waiting for him.
As soon as he inserted the cartridge into
the console and pressed the "start" button,
the room around him began to transform, reality
itself warping and reshaping to fit the world
of the game.
Fluorescent lights and stark white walls were
replaced by pixelated trees, and a winding
cobblestone path leading to a massive stone
castle.
The first enemy, a knight in black armor,
leaped into frame, and Dr. Furakawa raised
his sword, ready for combat.
But before he had a chance to deal the first
blow, it became clear that something wasn't
right.
The enemy knight suddenly disappeared, glitching
out of sight.
The cobblestones slowly began to drift into
the air, and so did Dr. Furakawa.
Just as suddenly as he lifted off, he dropped
back to the ground with a heavy thud.
Gravity was rapidly fluctuating, and he could
scarcely keep his balance.
In front of him, he could see random cubic
structures popping up out of nowhere, made
up of wood, stone, and ice.
"End the game!"
He called out desperately.
"Pull the plug, someone, please!"
Outside, one of the researchers watching the
experiment cut the power to the console, but
nothing happened.
The world refused to return to normal.
Security officers entered the area, and attempted
to remove Dr. Furakawa, but found that his
body still resembled an 8-bit video game character.
When they attempted to drag him out of the
ZK-class zone, he cried out in pain as his
body began to dissolve into static.
They had turned off the console, but they
were unable to pull him out.
The rest of the research team, horrified by
what they had witnessed, began to take measurements
of the reality failure scenario from outside
of the room.
The area now displayed a complete absence
of naturally occurring radiation, including
cosmic background radiation.
There was also evidence of time dilation,
reduction of light speed, and the gravity
fluctuations that Dr. Furakawa had first noticed.
With no way to remove Furakawa from this broken
reality, the area would have to be sealed
off, and he would be left inside.
There was no other option.
So, they constructed a concrete dome around
the testing site, and relocated the remaining
instances of SCP-591.
From that point on, testing was only conducted
using D-Class, no matter how much research
staff loved video games, or how vehemently
they insisted that they were "willing to roll
the dice."
They were barred from testing and encouraged
to pick up a VR headset for a much lower-risk
immersive gaming experience.
Over the years of testing following the Dr.
Furakawa incident, four more ZK-class scenarios
were created and contained.
Some of the individuals survived the incident
but were physically altered so greatly that
they would not be able to survive outside
of the ZK-class reality failure.
The only people who survived were unable to
readjust to their lives, continuing to live
as the main character of the game they were
playing.
At this point, testing was officially suspended
indefinitely, due not only to the loss of
human life but also the unpredictable and
highly dangerous nature of the damage being
done to reality on such a grand scale.
All instances of SCP-591 confiscated by the
Foundation are kept in a storage containment
vault, kept separate from any civilians or
their infrastructure by a distance of at least
500m.
It is also kept separate from other Foundation-controlled
containment facilities.
Unless it is being used for official, approved
testing by Level-3 staff, it is to remain
deactivated at all times.
Any ZK-class scenarios created by an instance
of SCP-591 will be contained via the construction
of a closed concrete dome, and given the designation
of Sector-W#.
Sectors W1 through W5, the currently existing
ZK-class scenarios, are monitored remotely
and kept highly classified.
Any personnel or test subjects located inside
one of these sectors will remain there indefinitely,
and be officially considered lost in action.
Any additional instances of SCP-591 located
in civilian stores, households, or any public
place are to be removed and contained immediately.
As the years have gone by, testing has indicated
a steady increase in the rake of a ZK-class
scenario being generated from a CK-class scenario.
Where it was once only a 1% chance, there
is now a 32% chance.
According to Wondertainment company records,
seized during a Foundation raid of one of
their toy factories, there are still plenty
of SCP-591 instances out there in the wild,
just waiting for some unsuspecting gamer to
fire them up and get lost in the story, literally.
If the documents found are accurate, there
are around 243 consoles and 1,300 consoles
still in circulation.
These also may or may not include a "Pocket
Pretendo" model that was developed as a prototype
but never officially released on the market.
If it was, and the chaos of the Pretendo system
is available in a portable form...well, it's
best not to think about that for too long.
The Foundation is doing its best to track
down the remaining Pretendo systems, but there
is no way to know for sure what distant corners
of the world they've made their way to.
So, when you're picking up a shiny new game
console, or a nostalgic vintage model to relive
some of your favorite childhood memories with,
take an extra close look at the label and
make sure you're getting the real thing.
Because if you're not careful...it just might
be Game Over.
Now go check out "SCP-1007 - Mr. Life and
Mr. Death" and "SCP-001 - A Simple Toymaker"
for more on the weird, whimsical world of
Dr. Wondertainment!